aujourd'hui on teste la caméra de galaxy
note 9 on va voir s'il est bien là on
est dans l'avion
donc on va voir si cette caméra est cool
si elle est bien enfin les tests en
faible luminosité dans les bonnes
luminosité dans les bonnes conditions
pas mal de choses et puis au final voir
du point de vue de la photo et de la
vidéo 6e 9 9 et brûlent oui où
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous parlais du samsung
galaxy note 9 jeux déjà fait le test
il ya quelques temps le galaxy note 9
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui est
assez incroyable
il a de la puissance il a un grand écran
le style est enfin moi j'ai vraiment
vraiment adoré l'expérience et j'ai pris
le temps de vous faire un test aussi sur
la partie photo vidéo j'ai voulu un
petit peu le détacher parce que je pense
que ça peut vraiment nécessité une vidéo
à part d'idées si vous voulez c'est de
vous ramener avec moi à berlin là où
j'ai pris effectivement le temps de le
tester de checker la photo la vidéo
durant tout mon voyage
il vous allez voir franchement je suis
hyper surpris
[Musique]
j'ai pas voulu tester toutes les
fonctionnalités complètes faire le tour
complet de tout ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce samsung galaxy note 9
l'idée c'était plutôt de voir
l'utilisation standard ce qu'on va en
faire c'est à dire quelques photos et
quelques vidéos lorsque les conditions
de lumière sont optimales et lorsqu'il
fait nuit
voilà tout simplement donc je vous
emmène dans le berlin la nuit je vous en
donne par les bas-fonds berlin dans les
clubs de berlin
[Musique]
bombay
allez vas-y allait même pas du tout pris
tôt
on commence avec la faible luminosité
bon on est sur un photophone n'est pas
sur un appareil photo n'est pas sur un
reflex abri de tout ce que vous voulez
donc on va pas avoir un rendu qui va
être complètement ouf estime néanmoins
que je trouve vraiment bien c'est
l'adaptabilité de cet appareil
la qualité n'est pas complètement dingue
lorsque vous filmez la nuit de l'autre
côté il lui faut de la lumière
c'est un grand classique mais je trouve
que nous sommes quand même plutôt pas
mal
maintenant lorsque vous passez à
condition de bonne luminosité là ça
change tout il est juste merveilleux le
rendu que ce soit en photo ou en vidéo
est vraiment vraiment vraiment aux
piscines
[Musique]
et en plus de ça ce que j'ai vraiment
apprécié avec lui c'est la stabilisation
il va venir compenser les tremblements
les mouvements et même lorsque vous
allez chercher à zoomer dans l'image
alors si vous ou mais à fond bien moment
vous allez récupérer du pixel li na va
pas être de bonne qualité mais va-t-elle
pouvoir sacrément en encaisser avant que
l'image se détériore au delà de ça
lorsque vous allez utiliser un peu en
mode macro j'ai fait des tests
directement sur mon bras
c'est assez incroyable parce que vous
allez pouvoir vraiment le rapprocher
choper du point de détail vraiment du
point de détail sur la peau sur les
poils par le poète poil c'est vraiment
le test que j'ai fait vous chopez
vraiment beaucoup de détails et ça
paraît je pense que c'est vraiment bien
sauf que au final ce samsung galaxy note
9 c'est un smartphone du point de vue de
la photo de la vidéo qui est vraiment un
peu passe partout
vous pouvez l'utiliser lorsque vous avez
vraiment un très grand ciel bleu très
grand soleil
neil la colorimétrie des photos est
vraiment bien sur la vidéo il encaisse
parfaitement bien et dès que la lumière
chute dès que vous avez un temps gris ou
alors carrément vous arrivez à des
conditions de faible luminosité le soir
pourquoi pas la nuit
il encaisse il fait le job c'est pas non
plus un appareil photo à 2500 3000 4000
euros mais néanmoins il fait vraiment
bien le job dans tous les produits que
sont sortis cette année
pour moi le galaxy s 9 plus qu'à la même
caméra que 99 fait partie de mon top 3
il y à cette caméra
il ya aussi celle du p 20 pro il ya
celle de l'iphone 10 salles donc si vous
voulez un smartphone avec un grand écran
avec un stylet qui va être excellent en
photos et en vidéo vous pouvez aller
sans aucun problème sans ce galaxy note
9 vous serez pas déçus d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse vous avez un lien en bas
dans la description quant à vous dites
moi ce que vous en pensez si vous avez
un galaxy note 9 ou carrément un x 9,9
plus dites moi aux commentaires que vous
en pensez est ce que vous êtes vraiment
satisfait du rendu photo vidéo est ce
que vous trouvez qu'il a quand même des
limites notamment faible luminosité vous
marquez tout ça en laisse du temps
ensemble
merci soyez ça je vous embrasse et à
très bientôt tous
[Musique]